dho has 32 percent market share globally
and don't need every region except for
the Americas for only a 16 percent
market share here FedEx dominates
holding 50 percent of the market share
followed up by UPS and in 2008 DHL
completely exited the US domestic
Express business but recently they've
actually re-entered the US market so how
did DHL the global shipping giant failed
to penetrate the US mark in the first
place and will they succeed this time
around make sure stick around till the
end to find out welcome to Hari Saudis
so let's start off with some brief
history DeeDee chose a she established a
lot later than UPS but actually earlier
than FedEx on September 25th 1969 it was
created by lost co-students a tree and a
lousy Larry Hillblom and Robert Lynn if
you look at the first letter of each of
your last names it spells DHL and that's
where the name came from they started to
provide door-to-door express delivery
service initially transferring documents
from San Francisco California to
Honolulu Hawaii in just one year they
guard up to 40 clients and start
expanding into BOM Los Angels in
Portland by 1971 they really focused on
expanding internationally which opened
up territories in the Far East and the
Pacific Rim in 1972 DHL international
became an official entity as they opened
the office in Hong Kong in that same
year they would open offices in Japan
and Singapore and by 1974 they would be
delivering 500,000 shipments per year
they expanded the service around the
world by the late 1970s and it really
excelled at providing cheap
international shipping thos are
specialized in international deliveries
through an air and sea as UPS
specializes in land deliveries and FedEx
specialize in air deliveries they
continue to expand internationally and
established more offices around the
world throughout the 1980s and 90s the
next big thing they did was in 1999 when
they popped 44 boys I'm 50
for the European and Asian networks and
in 2000 they launched the world's first
global SMS tracking service customers
could now track DHL shipments through
text messages and in 2002 Dutch post
increased her stake in the company to
51% making the majority stakeholder and
they have been that ever since in 2003
there burst into United States acquiring
the seattle-based carrier Airport Inc
for 1 billion dollars they would spend
an additional five billion dollars
expanding and promoting US operations so
what went wrong and the clear obvious
first problem is that there's intense
competition and they're entering an
established market they had to fight
against the shipping giant UPS and FedEx
who had already become highly efficient
and very precise in the US market and
another huge problem to deal with is
that most people in the United States
didn't even know what DHL was DHL is
huge outside of the United States but
even today within the u.s. DHL is not
the first thing that comes to mind when
you mentioned shipping as a result they
had to run huge marketing campaigns that
really drained their money in order to
get the word out about DHL FedEx and UPS
could completely avoid all of this and
really concentrate on making their
shipping faster and cheaper DHL had to
put up a lot of upfront capital in order
for people to a ship through DHL and the
thing is winning the trust of the public
is a long time intensive process this
made a really hard for them to compete
as it really was an uneven playing field
with them having a disadvantage they
hope that they can be the market
disruptors but clearly it wasn't as easy
as they expected to be if you're
entering a highly concentrated and very
efficient market it would be a good idea
to buy a company not a good presence in
the market already but diesel didn't do
this they decided to buy a low-quality
niche player named airborne who had a
very weak base this made it very tough
for them to expand as airborne didn't
have a good infrastructure already in
place
DHL had to invest their own money in or
to build new hubs get new delivery
trucks hired me employees they were
basically building from the ground up
this waste a lot of retirement money
which should have been spent and
thinking of how to compete with FedEx
and UPS they had acquired a much
stronger secret company ride the very
beginning they would have had a much
better chance this bad entry really
wasted lagdi chose energy and gave
competitors time to better their own
services and this really ended up
hurting DHL and then of course there was
the 2008 economic recession which is the
final blow to the company people
worshipping items much less often and
online of international orders
significantly decreased this
dramatically increased a time period
that would take for DHL USA to simply
break even this substantially increased
the financial stress from the company
and there was just too much for them to
continue to absorb at the storm that
year they had already cut 5,400
employees and I continued to incur
massive losses year after year most
people expected that DHL will shrink
their US operations on November 10th
2008 they announced that they were
completely withdrawn from the US
domestic service market the admin is
juggling for five years and didn't even
gain a significant amount of market
share so this was the most logical
choice they would continue to provide
international and not service to the
United States but they had to cut 9,500
jobs including 3,000 to 4,000 jobs in
the United States they would basically
be back to where they were before the
airborne Inc purchase the chief
executive of DHL Express stated that dho
really struggled as there was
overwhelming brand recognition for UPS
and FedEx in the United States they
racked up over 1 billion dollars in
losses per year over the past two years
and this was the clear choice yet spent
3.9 billion dollars in the restructuring
which is 1.9 billion dollars over the
two billion dollars of expected
restructuring costs if they didn't pull
out right then the whole group of dho
would have had a net loss in the year
2008 throughout the whole endeavor they
about ten billion dollars after their
withdrawal they were able to reduce
their us Express unit cost from five
point four billion dollars per year to 1
billion dollars per year this was
possible by reducing their groundhog
years in the United States from 412 to
103 animus ironic is that this
withdrawal as she helped all the
shipping carriers docks UPS was up 2.5%
FedEx was up 1.4 percent and - group was
up six point nine percent since then DHL
has been doing well and what they do
best but this has always been a little
gripe in their portfolio and wouldn't
you know it starting a couple of years
ago
DHL has started to relaunch in America
they have been offering the same day and
next day delivery services to all nine
retailers in Chicago New York and Los
Angeles and since then they have been
rapidly adding more cities every single
month after all they are the kings of
fast cost-effective delivery which is
exactly what the e-commerce space once
and they also have a huge opportunity
with Amazon as they were growing 25%
every single year and the thing is UPS
and FedEx have told Amazon that they
will not be scaling with their needs and
if you look at Amazon's recent
activities they may be teaming up with
DHL DHS US hub is it Cincinnati and
Amazon's new air hub is in the same city
analysts don't think that it's a
coincidence they all saw a parcel Metro
which is a third-party contract carrier
that business is based off of sourcing
third-party drivers who pick up packages
from retailers and warehouses and none
of them straight to the households this
really shortens the delivery time making
it really favorable as you may have
noticed details using a completely
different strategy this time around last
time they were trying to mark and spread
the word about DHL to millions of people
but this time they're targeting the
retailers and online e-commerce
businesses who need to ship their cars
out there able to capture a lot more
business using the same effort this new
strategy along with the fish and careful
spending that's really a lot of DHL to
go a long way in the US market
last year they delivered about 500
million packages now there's still a
long way to go as UPS delivered 750
million packages in just a holiday
season last year but they're definitely
making progress DHL is one of the
biggest shipping carriers in the world
and it is surprising if they haven't
made a deep impact on the US market yet
they already failed once miserably in
the early 2000s losing a lot of energy
and time but despite this they are
trying once again however this time
there are being a lot more cautious
spending a lot less money and opting for
a slow long-term growth this time
they're investing hundreds of millions
of dollars over several years instead of
a billion dollars right off the bat and
the results are clear while there is
total Dorf by UPS and FedEx in the
United States they're consistently
growing in Guinea market share but with
time this slow consistent growth can
definitely lead to dho of being a large
store in the United States market as
well but that's all I have for you guys
on da show make sure to comment down
below what company you would like me to
cover next also if you guys like this
video make up a lamp and consider
subscribing if you like
just didn't trust us on next